vous devez être monsieur benjamines
bonjour
vous pouvez me parler de vos patients
précédent en fait très fort serait mon
premier patient mon fils a un sens de
l'humour particulier tu veux quelque
chose à peine la fondation make a wish
m'en veux aussi que katy perry me
tailler une pipe
il se réveille tous les jours à la même
heure au regard de la télé tous les
jours à la même heure et il mange à la
même heure tous les jours de gaufres une
saucisse tu les amis comme ça pour faire
de grosses qu une petite [ __ ] s'appelait
sarah porter les formulaires du divorce
j'suis pas prêt le chat ça fait deux ans
et demi là c'est quoi le nombre d'années
magique après lequel tu seras enfin prêt
si tu te réveilles avec tt guéri c'est
quoi le premier truc que tu ferais c'est
une carte des attractions les plus
minables visibles sur les routes de
cette nation le trouble plus profond du
monde le plus gros bovins du monde
qu'est ce qui vous fait croire que
j'accepterai tu veux laisser emmener mon
fils en voyage il ne va rien lui arriver
je vous le jure
tu as déjà mangé un skin jean non ils
disent quoi chez toi qu'aucune autre
chaudron sur slim jim regarde ça le plus
gros bovins du monde ça va ouais et
huawei
tu veux qu'on l'emmène salut je
m'appelle ben inspecté un pervers non je
suis pas un pervers
c'est exactement ce qui interdirait je
m'appelle dot prévoir il ya une place
pour moi dans votre équipe de pervers
si l'action
je veux aller voir nos pères ah oui il
sait tirer quand j'avais 3 ans
bonjour je veux voir bob nick luxe et
trevor si mon nom lui parle pas dites
lui que je suis en chaise roulante et si
ça lui parle pas non plus dit lui que je
suis son fils
et si même ça ça lui parle pas dites lui
que c'est qu'une sombre merde je ne
crois pas que ce soit une bonne idée que
vous soignez le trop proche de trevor ou
que vous fassiez des promesses que vous
ne tiendrait pas est ce que tu as envie
de l'inviter à dîner où il s'il te plaît
t'es pas mon père ok je peux seulement
td non c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai que
tu veux mais au fond tu penses pas à moi
je vais appeler la fondation make-a-wish
ils ont vérifié tiberi nous retrouver
dans un motel tu veux quelque chante
quoi pendant qu'elle s'occupe de toi
fireworks